hey guys I'm gonna teach it right I'm
Martin Freeman I play Everett Ross
Sheree and we're going to do what you
want I got a guy go Phil difference
would you rather have to wear a black
panther suit every time you left your
house I'm the same vibe famous oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah for sure
I would say Black Panther suit yeah yeah
why because I made it yeah of course
I've been quiet absorb sound to run our
walls cause of course given you meaning
to talk to the hand would you rather
have nakiya's ring blades for hands or
Thor's hammer for legs I kind of like my
hands you know I think I could cope with
Thor hammer legs no fear like yeah I
might not walk on Van falls on the four
legs really want it's solid it's
rectangular and you can just like yeah
what are you gonna do is ring minute
yeah you just kill everything would you
rather have a fight for the last slice
of pizza against Sheree or x-men mutant
storm storm cuz then I'll just get a
piece and it's raining okay I'm gonna go
it sure just because I think if I'm
fighting storm you can get a little out
of hand
yeah yeah yeah I like lightning and yeah
yeah ruin it would be no pizza I think I
would fight storm we could find yeah we
good fight would you rather be big
spooned by T'Challa Warwick hobby after
a night of Netflix and chilling do you
want to be big spoon by teacher
[Applause]
I'm gonna go for T'Challa because I just
know him a bit better - that's true yeah
I'm easy other way car made of vibranium
or an indestructible cell phone made out
of indestructible car talk about a cell
phone oh yeah Mike calls now I'm guy
with a car with a cell phone
I'm gonna get the car I'll go for the
cell phone I use myself phone more than
a hammer I don't have your high yet so
if it falls and you know it's it's
indestructible I drop my flat literally
I just got my phone and I dropped it the
same game and crack the screen and I
felt some type of way about it would you
rather find out your uber driver is
mbaku or an angry ho happy vehicle yeah
right but Ibaka would take up most of
the cost base you leave it alone but
nobody
I'm very Hulk as well I'm back yeah
that's not it that's not pretty I think
if it was a Hulk it would be a really
short ride and over died angry Hulk to
me has no redeeming qualities at all
about giving insanities their egos are
you
mbaku is sort of funny yeah in buckle
yes yeah
would you rather consume a heart shape
herb that gives you superhuman strength
or immortality I kind of I'm quite
interested in alternative immortality
sounds amazing but is it like
immortality like death becomes her like
this your body like Robin you just don't
know okay so like like like right now a
completely fabulous for the forever yeah
I think I'm going to tell you I've never
seen a human strength because I think
immortality is ultimately unnatural
towards your way we're supposed to be
superhuman strength I don't want to be
around for too long yeah yeah what kind
of immortality is it is it that I'm
gonna be like healthy or is it like my
body's gonna shut down but I'll just be
alive just like alive like here ya know
kill me I know your friends will be gone
I'll make new friends would you ever
find out you're the Dorma logic once it
lists or the advantages Oh normalize a
is fierce I think I have more time to
live with their injures actually you
know what no I'd rather the daughter
came out for me because I like looking
at
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that's it would you rather is
healthy
[Music]